now to our other top story tonight more
people are getting hit and killed by
cars the state of nevada has already
seen more deadly crashes this year than
last just this morning a crash shut down
an intersection in spring valley
happened near flamingo and jones metro
police say a car hit a pedestrian that
person taken to the hospital
statewide we are seeing an increase in
these types of crashes not only
pedestrians being hit and killed but
also motorcyclists bicyclists scooters
too madison kimbrough on this story give
the answers to what needs to be done
here she is
leticia lowe rides the bus every day and
says she has seen far too many
distracted drivers there's been people
getting hit left and right from doing it
you have people who are drunk people are
on drugs people who just are not aware
or actively paying attention to what's
going on around them according to the
nevada office of traffic safety there
has been more than a 50 percent increase
in motorcyclists hit and killed this
year erin breen with the road equity
alliance says it's time we start looking
at las vegas as a commuter's town and
really focus on the people around us
develop roads and a system that moves
people instead of moves cars we let you
go fast in the city and and to me that's
the first thing that has to change if
we're going to seriously talk about
reducing the number of pedestrians
killed we need to change the speed that
people are traveling breen says we need
more traffic lights and cameras along
with increasing the number of speed
limit signs in all areas and not just
the commercial ones if we put up more
signs that say what the speed limit is
that the prudent driver
will slow their
their speed down yes it's not just the
core of las vegas anymore now we're
seeing that those dangerous st streets
spread further and further to the north
and the south and the east and the west
that was madison kimbrough reporting
failure to yield to pedestrians is the
number one reason for these fatalities
along with speed impairment and
distractions all contributing